Traducteur: Gehad Salem
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je suis profondément ému.
Vous savez, il y a deux ans,
j'ai rencontré trois grands hommes
qui m'ont impacté,
qui m'ont boosté dans ma défense
pour l'humanité et la nature.
Il s'agit en fait de Nicolas Hulot,
le récent ministre écologiste français,
qui a préfacé mon dernier livre
sur le climat.
Il s'agit de l'actuel ministre
écologiste belge de la Wallonie.
Vous savez en Wallonie,
nous avons les Flamands
qui sont des anglophones,
et les Wallons qui sont des francophones.
L'actuel ministre écologiste wallon
s'appelle Carlo Di Antonio
qui m'a boosté lorsque je fus en Belgique
en tant que bénéficiaire d'une bourse
d'excellence de l'académie belge.
Il m'a invité à participer en tant que
les trois jeunes noirs,
au parlement développement
durable de la Wallonie.
Il m'a boosté parce que
je me suis rendu compte
qu'en fait la priorité des pays du nord,
c'est l'alimentation durable.
Nous sommes en pleine guerre.
Vous savez ce qui m'a encore boosté,
c'est la rencontre d'un grand député,
d'un grand parlementaire européen,
que vous connaissez tous,
il s'appelle José Ovi.
Mon activisme se fonde en fait
sur ces trois grands hommes
qui ont changé ma vie.
Aujourd'hui, je parlerai
de « silent war »,
la guerre silencieuse
et les armes invisibles.
Nous sommes aujourd'hui
à une ère - une ère géologique -
que nous appelons Anthropocène.
C'est l'ère géologique dédiée à l'homme.
En fait, Nicolas Hulot a eu à démontrer
à la vingt-deuxième conférence
des parties sur le climat
que l'avenir de l'humanité dépend de nous.
L'homme qui est au centre en fait de
la dénaturalisation des milieux naturels,
l'homme qui dégrade l'environnement,
se retrouve aujourd'hui confronté
à l'extermination de sa destinée.
Vous savez, il y a un physicien russe
qui s'appelle Vladimir Vernadsky
qui aujourd'hui est au cœur
de cette anthropocène.
L'anthropocène, depuis Vladimir Vernadsky,
depuis les années 1800, était démontrée
comme effet boostant
ce qu'on appelle la noosphère.
Avant de partir aujourd'hui,
vous devez savoir
ce qu'on appelle la noosphère.
La noosphère, c'est tout simplement
la sphère de l'intelligence humaine.
L'homme a la quête du gain facile,
l'homme, du fait de l'industrialisation,
l'homme du fait des sociétés capitalistes
qui sont aujourd'hui en fait
au cœur de l'économie,
qu'on appelle l'économie linéaire.
Une économie qui ne dépend
en fait que du capitalisme.
Une économie qui ne produit
que de la richesse,
mais qui ne valorise pas,
et qui ne préserve pas
l'humanité et la nature.
Vous savez mes chers amis,
l'avenir de l'humanité dépend
réellement de chacun de nous.
Nous qui sommes ici présents,
nous devenons des missionnaires,
des missionnaires de la nature
et de l'humanité.
Il est vrai lors de ma présentation,
je suis un vegan, le vegan c'est celui
qui aujourd'hui est supérieur
à un végétarien.
Le vegan, pour porter des chaussures,
ne portera pas des chaussures en cuir,
mais portera des chaussures
en cuir synthétique,
fabriqués donc artificiellement.
Le vegan, lui, il ne consommera pas
de la viande,
le vegan ne consommera pas du poisson,
le vegan ne consommera pas
du lait de vache,
le vegan ne consommera donc pas du fromage
qui dérive du lait de vache.
En fait le vegan au-delà du fait
qu'il est végétarien
parce que le végétarien lui par exemple
un lacto végétarien ne consommera pas
de la viande,
mais consommera quand même du lait.
Voyez l'ovo végétarien
qui ne consommera pas de la viande,
mais consommera du lait et des œufs.
Vous savez le vegan lui, malgré le fait
qu'il s'est interdit la viande,
le poisson, les œufs,
et toutes les variétés
parce que cela menace les animaux,
vous savez, il s'interdit même
de porter des ceintures en cuir.
Vous êtes surpris aujourd'hui,
que je me suis habillé
aussi simplement que possible.
Mes chers amis le vegan, c'est un fou,
le vegan, c'est celui
qui respecte le bien-être animal.
Cette année, il a été voté une loi
en Belgique
pour préserver le bien-être animal
en Wallonie.
J'ai contribué vous savez,
quand je parlais
du ministre Carlo Di Antonio,
à l'élaboration de la loi
où interdit le glyphosate en Wallonie,
lors de ce parlement
développement durable.
Depuis janvier 2019, est interdit
en Wallonie en Belgique
le glyphosate le Roundup de Monsanto
à la suite donc de ce parlement-là.
Mes chers amis,
nous sommes en pleine guerre,
une guerre microbiologique,
nos cellules, vous savez, nos tissus,
nos organes sont en pleine guerre.
C'est pour cela que notre système
de défense immunitaire
que sont les polynucléaires,
les macrophages
qui vont capter, internaliser,
phagocyter, digérer,
dégrader, présenter les molécules
étrangères
sont en pleine guerre
parce que nous ne cessons
de polluer notre organisme,
nous ne cessons de consommer
des aliments toxiques,
des aliments qui sont nocifs
pour notre santé,
les pesticides, qui aujourd'hui
en pleine guerre,
polluent tous nos cours d'eau.
Vous savez les réseaux trophiques,
on appelle encore la chaîne alimentaire,
les réseaux trophiques, c'est l'ensemble
donc de tout ce que nous pouvons manger.
Vous voyez, dans la nature,
il y a les végétaux
qu'on appelle encore les autotrophes.
Aujourd'hui vous devez savoir que
l'autotrophe, c'est un être vivant
capable de transformer lui-même
le carbone minéral en carbone organique.
L'homme carnivore est un hétérotrophe,
il va consommer ce carbone,
déjà transformé par les végétaux
grâce au phénomène de la photosynthèse.
L'homme carnivoreaujourd'hui a dépassé
la limite même du règne carnivore.
Vous savez, il y a un mot que j'ai inventé
qu'on appelle « azitosphère ».
On a parlé, tout à l'heure,
de l'anthropocène.
Nous avons dépassé l'anthropocène
qui est l'ère géologique dédiée à l'homme.
Nous sommes aujourd'hui
à une ère que j'appelle azitosphère.
L'être humain carnivore,
qui massacre le bien-être animal,
n'a plus peur du sang humain.
Toutes les sociétés humaines
qui respectent le bien-être animal,
ont respecté le bien-être des humains.
Alors, je nous invite chacun et tous
à désormais porter de prix,
à respecter le bien-être des animaux,
ainsi désormais,
nous allons respecter les hommes,
nous allons nous respecter nous-mêmes,
et nous allons respecter
l'humanité et la nature.
Soyez des messagers !